my college or New York Magazine and sex  Diaries and it's turning into a docu  series  you are my next Iris this is the love of  my life my best friend I was like it was  amazing I'm definitely in love with John  all right I bring a threesome maybe I'm  a little addicted to Casual Sex You Like  It  I have been speaking with someone on  Tick Tock and it's time to meet  for me that means I like multiple  partners  despite my bloodier Tendencies I am a  sucker for romance I described it as a  flirtatious friendship that is sexually  rewarding I'm anxious about what it's  going to be like in the bedroom  I don't know what's gonna happen well  it's been a long time since somebody  made me happy  things that I'm open to all  possibilities  who I'm supposed to be  are we having pancakes  you know those promised pancakes